Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Est-ce que vous vous êtes déjà demandé
comment vos grands-parents passaient
leurs vacances et leurs week-ends
dans leur jeunesse ?
Moi, j’ai demandé aux miens.
Mon premier grand-père m’a raconté
comment il construisait des cabanes
et jouait à la rivière.
Des souvenirs incroyables
à seulement 10 kilomètres de chez lui.
Mon grand-père maternel m’a raconté
qu’il avait fait Paris-Nice à vélo,
à 15 ans.
J’étais contente de le savoir,
je pensais être la seule de la famille
à faire ces choses à vélo.
Surtout, on s’est retrouvé
sur une notion essentielle :
l’aventure.
L’imprévu, ne pas savoir
ce qui va se passer
et aimer ça quand même.
Les galères nombreuses
mais toujours trouver une solution.
Et dormir sous les étoiles,
manger assis par terre,
pédaler pendant des heures sous la pluie
en serrant les dents pour que ça passe.
Et surtout, les rencontres.
Vous savez, ces gens qui sont toujours là
pour vous aider à réparer votre vélo,
à vous indiquer le chemin
ou à vous faire dormir chez eux.
Surtout, je me suis fait
la remarque que cette autonomie,
ce « faire par soi-même »,
n’est pas vraiment
encouragé dans notre société.
Pas encouragé, mais extrêmement valorisé.
Marco Polo, Tintin,
Sylvain Tesson, Mike Horn.
Vous les imaginez le nez collé
à leur itinéraire recommandé
par 10 000 internautes ?
Ou bien de mettre trois étoiles
sur leur cabane Airbnb ?
Parce que faut pas déconner,
le poêle à bois était pas top.
Est-ce qu’ils nous feraient
vraiment autant rêver ?
J’ai eu un déclic quand
j’ai parlé de ça à un ami
qui travaille dans une start-up,
dans une sorte d’agence de voyages,
et il m’a dit : « Mais Amélie,
les gens n’ont pas le temps d’organiser.
Et puis, ils ne savent pas
comment s’y prendre. »
Comment ça, « on n’a pas le temps » ?
On a cinq semaines de congés payés,
on n’en a jamais eu autant.
On fait partie des pays les mieux lotis.
Comment ça,
« on ne sait pas s’organiser » ?
Mes grands-parents, je veux bien,
mais nous, on a toutes les informations
disponibles en un clic.
Les infrastructures
pour se déplacer, se loger,
les offres touristiques pléthoriques.
On attend et même
si bien, qu’on a même créé
une économie de la recommandation.
Ce sont tous ces acteurs
qui nous aident à faire le tri
et qui nous disent où exactement dormir,
quel tracé choisir
ou prendre sa belle photo.
Ce sont les guides de voyage,
la presse, les médias,
les influenceurs, les blogueurs,
les agences de voyages,
les agences de communication.
Avec ça, on ne sait toujours pas
se débrouiller.
Étrange.
Cette logique mise en lumière par mon ami,
c'est celle de l'industrie touristique.
Elle nous a conduits
à faire reculer notre autonomie,
nos super valeurs humanistes
de gratuité, de spontanéité
et bien plus de choses encore.
Et tout cela, en seulement un siècle.
Pour nous en rendre compte,
j’ai préparé un rapide état des lieux
que j’ai appelé « 120 ans de tourisme :
du rien au trop-plein ».
Prenons une frise chronologique
de 1900 à nos jours
et quelques repères pour s’y retrouver.
1936 : les premiers congés payés,
deux semaines pour souffler,
un immense progrès social.
1950, quatorze ans après :
l’ouverture du premier Club Med.
Regardons en détail
quatre éléments majeurs
de l’histoire du tourisme.
Premier élément :
la première expédition touristique
en Antarctique.
C’est 1958.
Qu’en est-il aujourd’hui ?
4 000 visiteurs dans les années 90,
10 000 en 2006
et 56 000 avant la crise Covid.
56 000 visiteurs
qui viennent chaque année,
se masser sur une toute
petite parcelle de banquise,
riche en biodiversité,
donc extrêmement fragile,
pendant les quatre mois
les moins froids de l’année.
Mais soyez rassurés,
on a pris des mesures,
pour éviter l’effet de foule,
on a limité les bateaux à 500 passagers.
Nous sommes sauvés.
Il semblerait que, depuis les années 2000,
le « selfie manchot » soit
devenu un rêve universel.
Du coup, on est sur
une croissance exponentielle
avec des visiteurs qui doublent
tous les 15 ans.
On attend 100 000 visiteurs
dans les années 2030.
Deuxième élément :
la naissance du « Guide du Routard ».
C’est intéressant parce que c’est le début
de l’ère de la recommandation.
C’est 1973.
Philippe Gloaguen, de retour
d’un périple à travers le monde,
a l’idée, très intéressante,
d’écrire un guide à destination
des jeunes fauchés qui voyagent comme lui.
C’est le succès qu’on connaît,
aujourd’hui on en vend 2,5 millions par an
C’est énorme.
Mais surtout, entre temps,
la recommandation a changé de camp.
Instagram est aujourd’hui
la première source d’inspiration
et de choix en termes de voyage,
surtout pour les moins de 35 ans.
Pourquoi pas ?
Mais, chaque année,
des millions de voyageurs
traversent le monde pour reprendre
l’exacte photo qu’ils ont vue
sur Instagram.
Des photos qui sont prises
dans des lieux magnifiques
et qui sont aujourd’hui en surtourisme.
Le problème, il est avéré
et il est mondial.
Si bien que, de la Nouvelle-Zélande
au Wyoming, aux États-Unis,
les campagnes institutionnelles
se multiplient,
en essayant de décourager,
moquer, quelquefois,
ces comportements mimétiques.
En France, en 2019, WWF
a même créé une campagne
demandant aux Instagrameurs
de ne plus localiser les photos
prises dans les lieux naturels
pour éviter les effets de foule.
Troisième élément :
la naissance de l’aviation commerciale.
Symboliquement, on la place en 1914,
c’est la première fois qu’un passager
a payé son billet pour faire,
en l’occurrence, un trajet
de 30 minutes en Floride.
Mais il a fallu quand même
des années et des années pour que,
avec l’apparition du low cost
et la baisse des prix dans les années 90,
les usages décollent -
ou déconnent, c’est selon.
Aujourd'hui, on est sur 4,4 milliards
de passagers par an.
Difficile de savoir si on est
dans le trop-plein.
4,4 milliards, ça ne nous parle pas trop.
Sauf si j’ajoute que 90 % de l’humanité
n’a jamais pris l’avion.
C’est donc 10 % qui voyagent énormément
et puis les pays émergents
qui veulent faire comme nous.
On est comme sur l’Antarctique
sur une croissance exponentielle.
On prévoit 8 milliards
de passagers en 2030.
Dernier élément :
la naissance de Airbnb.
Là, c’est beaucoup plus récent, 2008 :
deux Américains ont l’idée de sous-louer
leur colocation à San Francisco et
empochent 1000 euros en trois jours.
Le concept est génial.
Il débarque au bout
de quelques années en Europe.
Qu’en est-il du trop-plein ?
Barcelone.
Les grèves anti-touristes se multiplient.
En cause la dégradation
de la qualité de vie.
La touristification, la hausse des loyers
et l’incapacité
pour les habitants de se loger.
Parce que les locations sont
réservées aux vacanciers.
De ce bref état des lieux,
on peut établir deux constats.
Le premier, c’est que le tourisme,
même quand il naît d’une belle idée,
quand il passe à grande échelle,
il a des effets environnementaux
et sociaux dévastateurs.
Le deuxième constat,
c’est que le trop-plein,
depuis les années 2000,
arrive extrêmement vite.
Les usages se diffusent extrêmement vite
parce que la mondialisation
et les réseaux sociaux
ont fait naître des rêves universels
pour tout le monde et ce, très rapidement.
J’ai un cinquième élément - il y a du rab.
C’est le développement
de la micro-aventure.
La micro-aventure, c’est le fait
de partir à l’aventure autour de chez soi.
Pas besoin de partir dans l'Himalaya.
Pour quelques jours, on prend un vélo,
ses chaussures de rando, un TER,
on se retrouve dans la nature,
qu’on soit citadin, aguerri ou non,
on vit tous l’aventure
près de chez soi toute l’année.
Génial.
C’est un peu la solution
que le tourisme n’attendait plus.
Sobre, durable, local - génial.
On comprend du coup que la presse
s’en soit emparée rapidement,
et les stratégies touristiques.
C’était en 2017.
Il y a eu les entrepreneurs,
les start-uppers, les applications,
les plateformes de réservation -
vous me voyez venir.
Est-ce qu’en quatre ans,
on pourrait déjà être au trop-plein ?
Je vous laisse regarder.
En fait, en France, nos milieux naturels
ont extrêmement souffert
les deux dernières années,
car nous sommes restés en France tous
à vouloir nous reconnecter à la nature.
Il y a eu la surfréquentation,
mais il y a aussi eu les incivilités
qui dérangent la faune et la flore.
Parce qu’on n’a plus vraiment les codes.
Cent ans d’industrie du tourisme
et de société de consommation
ont profondément changé
notre rapport à la nature.
Si je suis là ce soir, c’est parce
qu’on est à un point de bascule.
Vous ne le savez peut-être pas,
mais les parcs ont pris des mesures
restrictives qui s’imposaient.
On va perdre notre liberté,
la gratuité totale
que nous avons en France qui est
presque une exception mondiale.
Est-ce que vous avez essayé
de bivouaquer en Belgique ?
C’est interdit.
Ou de faire une randonnée
de plusieurs jours en Nouvelle-Zélande ?
Il faut réserver des mois à l’avance
et payer chaque hébergement.
Passez votre week-end
dans un parc national
aux États-Unis ?
Il faudra payer le prix d'entrée.
Ou bien juste faire une simple randonnée
sur un sentier balisé en Argentine
ou dans d’autres pays ?
Ça n'existe pas.
Tout est de l’ordre
de la propriété privée.
On a une chance incroyable en France,
sans vraiment s’en rendre compte.
Parce que cette liberté, pour la garder,
il faut avoir inculqué
de la conscience, de la connaissance
et de l’humilité.
Ce n’est pas vraiment
le choix de société qu’on a fait.
Alors, face à ce constat, le secteur
touristique propose des solutions.
Ce sont les mêmes en France
et aux quatre coins du monde.
La première, ce sont donc
des mesures restrictives,
limiter les accès.
C’est, par exemple, mettre des quotas
comme sur l’île de Porquerolles,
dans le Var.
Mettre en place un système de réservation
comme pour les Calanques
à partir du printemps prochain.
Ou interdire : on n’a plus le droit
de bivouaquer en Chartreuse,
et dans le Mercantour,
par exemple, depuis cet été.
Ce sont des mesures nécessaires
à très court terme mais sont-elles
vraiment des solutions d’avenir ?
Est-ce que la solution, c’est tout
interdire et de réduire ?
Qui voudrait vivre dans ce monde-là ?
Deuxième solution,
la gestion des flux
par le marketing et la promotion.
Il y a dix ans, les acteurs
de la recommandation
nous proposaient les 10 sites
incontournables à ne pas manquer.
Dix sites qui sont
aujourd’hui en surtourisme
et c’est problématique.
Du coup, on innove et on
nous propose les cinq randos,
ou mieux, les cinq spots nature
où personne ne va.
(Rires)
Est-ce qu’on a vraiment une solution ?
Ou est-ce qu’on déplace
un tout petit peu le problème ?
Il y a d’autres solutions,
mais ce qu’elles ont en commun,
c’est de chercher à réduire
les effets négatifs
sans jamais travailler sur les causes.
Ça s’appelle des stratégies de
mitigation, mitiger les effets négatifs.
Vous connaissez, il y en a
plein dans notre société,
c’est par exemple la compensation carbone.
Quand on propose de payer
plus cher le billet d’avion
pour replanter des arbres.
Le plus efficace,
c’est juste de moins émettre.
Ou le tri du plastique -
on se dit : « Je fais une bonne action. »
Sauf qu’en France, on ne peut
recycler que 30 % du plastique.
Le seul moyen d’éviter
la pollution plastique,
c’est juste de moins produire
et de moins consommer.
En parallèle, il y a une autre approche,
c’est simplement de s’adapter,
de revoir en profondeur
nos modes de pensée,
nos modes de vie,
notre façon de produire et de consommer.
Ça s’appelle la stratégie d’adaptation.
Moi, c’est la partie que je préfère
parce que c’est la plus enthousiasmante.
Il faut tout réinventer dans notre monde.
Surtout, ça fait la part belle
à d'autres acteurs.
Ceux qu’on appelle gentiment
les idéalistes, les rebelles,
les créatifs, ceux qui ont
des idées un peu radicales,
ceux qui osent remettre en question
un système économique,
qui profite à tous.
Et là, il faut que je vous avoue
quelque chose.
Je fais moi-même partie
de la poignée d’entrepreneurs
qui ont démocratisé la micro-aventure
en 2017, en France.
Et quand j’ai vu que ça prenait
un tel engouement très rapidement,
j’ai choisi de faire un pas de côté
et j’ai ouvert une école
pour adultes au format associatif.
Elle fait la part belle à l’autonomie,
à l’apprentissage sur le terrain,
au développement de l’esprit critique -
Un peu comme on le fait ce soir.
C’est vraiment
une toute petite initiative.
Pas de quoi être
l’entrepreneur de l’année.
Pas de quoi non plus revendre
ma boîte à cinq ans.
J’avais envie de montrer qu’on pouvait
encore agir, entreprendre différemment,
si on a envie de mettre
l’intérêt général et le bien public
vraiment au centre de tout.
Stratégie d’adaptation.
Et si, fort du constat que nous venons
de dresser, on prenait un grand virage ?
Si on remplaçait la consommation
par l’éducation ?
Imaginez, en 2030, que l’écologie
soit enseignée au collège et au lycée
avec une partie sur le voyage.
Comment voyager sobrement ?
Et comment faire autre chose
que voyager pendant son temps libre ?
Imaginez que chaque année,
deux régions françaises soient fermées
au tourisme pour laisser la nature
se régénérer
et qu’on propose aux habitants
d’aider à en prendre soin,
à la régénérer, à apprendre
à être avec la nature.
Imaginez des maisons de l’aventure
dans chaque ville,
libres d’accès, avec un thé glacé
on regarde les cartes avec un animateur.
Des soirées documentaires, des débats.
Ça mettrait des années
à changer les mentalités,
mais est-ce que ça ne vaudrait pas
le coup de commencer dès maintenant ?
J’imagine ce que vous vous dites,
que ce sont des beaux rêves,
que c’est de l’ordre de la puissance
publique et politique.
Certes, mais qu’est-ce qu’on peut faire,
nous, demain, à notre échelle,
de manière très concrète ?
J'ai trois pistes d'action
à vous proposer.
La première est de cultiver
notre imagination
au lieu de l’inspiration
qu’on trouve en ligne.
Travailler notre envie, notre curiosité,
c’est la meilleure des solutions
pour avoir d’autres rêves
et d’autres vacances que tout le monde.
La deuxième piste d’action,
c’est de repasser par le local,
d’éviter les intermédiaires,
de passer par des petits guides locaux
et de demander aux habitants.
Ils vous donneront les meilleurs conseils,
ceux que vous ne trouverez
jamais sur Internet.
Troisième piste : faites-vous initier.
On a ici des milliers d’associations,
de fédérations, de clubs alpins
qui préexistaient
à l’industrie touristique.
Avec des bénévoles qui balisent,
qui entretiennent les sentiers,
qui transmettent leur savoir
et leurs connaissances.
En fait, les solutions sont déjà là.
Il s’agit juste de changer d’échelle
pour éviter de reproduire
une massification,
aujourd’hui problématique,
par une autre massification
qu’on appelle sobre, durable, green,
ce que vous voulez.
Nous sommes réellement
à un point de bascule,
nous nous devons de reconquérir
notre rapport à la nature
et notre temps libre.
Nous devons remettre
du sens et des valeurs
dans la manière dont nous passons
nos vacances, nos week-ends.
Faire naître d’autres rêves
pour la jeune génération
que ceux de poster
des paysages sur Instagram.
Il existe encore dans ce monde
des choses qui ne s’achètent pas.
Et l'aventure en est une.
On apprend des savoir-faire,
des savoir-être
que ni parents ni école ne vous
transmettront, c’est l’école de la vie.
Ça exige de la sueur, du temps ; ça
instruit par l’expérience mais ça grandit.
Surtout, on y apprend
une chose essentielle :
le sandwich, posé sur les genoux,
après une longue matinée de marche.
On y comprend que le juste assez
a davantage de saveur
que le trop-plein.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)